tous les jours il s'entraîne il ne
pourrait pas imaginer une vie sans sport
qui m'allait courage de la nuit arnaud
huguet souffre d'infirmité motrice
cérébrale depuis la naissance des
lésions irréversibles qui provoque
troubles de la coordination et de la
part arnaud via sainte clotilde
avec sabine handicapée elle aussi boyer
ml on est vraiment au moins que dit
qu'au temps quant à elle je peux pas vu
et peut-être mois ci peut pas bu pour
moi c'est une voie que le bond du mal
n'est qu'en mai le temps du cab et le
dieu nous protège le super à que je veux
qu à laver la mort pour le meilleur ou
pour le pire pour le milieu bull bul
salle des voix à l'heure du café sur la
table de la salle à manger quelques
photos souvenirs moment - des photos de
sabine également et des lourds
traitements subis quand elle était
enfant
pour tenter de corriger les effets de la
polio à l'engouement que moi et c'est à
travers le sport que ces deux là se sont
connus à marcher un peu
le javelot et voilà nous del diablo
elle et moi et puis il y à mélodie et
annabelle 22 ans deux filles qui vont
tout à fait bien et qui réussissent à
l'école
pour moi c'est une lui formule 1 mais
leur promenade comme la même a même une
autre étape
je vais une femme et des enfants mais
veilleux et voilà
[Musique]
d'accord il ya des choses sont
nécessaires sabine kehm oui mais jamais
des propos lire il arrive alliés mais
pas pour longtemps
si vous êtes tous les deux et en voilà
et dans le jeu c'est la vue c'est
magnifique c'est bon ok voilà au caire
tous les matins arnaud par travailler en
beauté notre matériel
à sa taille direction le centre de saint
denis
c'est quoi ton travail et nettoyer les
meubles de la cour les poubelles pour
nettoyer les espaces communs de deux
immeubles de saint denis
arnaud touche environ 300 euros + 800
euros d'allocations handicapés comme
sabine ça ne fait pas beaucoup pour
faire vivre la famille
mais je peux le plus pas plus malheureux
que ça je vais voir que dans ma tête je
me dis ya plus malheureux que moi
[Musique]
c'est maintenant l'heure d'aller faire
les courses
oui je suis prêt
le médiateur
[Musique]
chaussures c'est difficile surtout c'est
pour pencher bon effet lefebvre le mieux
- les mains fait par un petit écran
c'est cette remet dans wave et voilà
jalel dans lé money dans molleton le dos
et onu c'est à dire on est heureux comme
home ou bien poisson dans l'eau
[Musique]
65 les serena
dans des paquets fabuleux qu'est ce que
c'est parfois blessant le regard des
autres oui c'est quelque fois c'est
warner en souffrent encore parfois un
peu le regard des autres bah
oui oui oui oui je veux pas moi qui vais
beaucoup mais il faut parler poupe avec
un écrin qu'est ce que tu ressens dans
ces cas-là mais heureusement que je tue
pas comme les autres parfois tu en
connais très très en colère
ben voilà c'est vrai je me cache aussi
par hugues ans
dans
les fouilles
numéro gagne c
c'est le top mais ce but afin que me
sens
l'après midi nous retrouvons arnaud et
sabine à champ fleuri depuis cinq ans
arnaud dirige le club rolland georget
qui accueille valides et non valides
aller doucement
et c'est vous le président ici chez moi
cruel d'un oui pour être même nom la
gamme jamais le lui c'est vrai que le
fus fatigué mais
sans jalousie pas
[Musique]
le sport c'est vital pour toi ah oui
c'est beaucoup plus tard dans la nuit
y a un peu triché mais on ne l aime pas
la kryte anneaux on veut enlever le bas
tu es
c'est quand même ça
[Musique]
m